- [Sal] We're now
going to talk about one of
the most significant figures
in all of human history,
and that is Siddhartha Gautama,
who would later be known
as Buddha, as the awakened
one, or the enlightened one.
Now before we get into his life,
let's think about the
context in which he was born.
So we see from this timeline,
most accounts place his
birth at around 563 BCE,
although there are some
historians who think that he
might have been born about
100, 150 years later than that.
But either way, that
would've been near the end of
the Vedic Period.
And the Vedic Period is
named after the Vedas,
these Hindu scriptures
written by those Indo-Aryans
who came into India,
most historians believe,
around 1500 BCE, or maybe before that.
Now by the time of Siddhartha's birth,
Hinduism was really
starting to take shape.
Many of the things that
we would now recognize as
modern day Hindu practice already existed.
And he was born into that world.
Now on this map here you
see the major sites of
Buddha's life.
He's born in Lumbini,
modern day southern Napal,
he eventually meditates at
Bodh Gaya under the Bodh tree
where he reaches enlightenment.
He does his first preaching at Sarnath,
and then he eventually dies at Kushinagar.
And to modern Buddhists,
these are still considered
major pilgrimage sites.
So he's born, according
to tradition, at Lumbini.
His mother is in transit
and born along the way
at Lumbini.
His mother dies shortly afterwards,
he's raised by his aunt,
but his father in some accounts is a king,
a chieftain, and he's able
to give the young Siddhartha
Gautama a very good,
a very sheltered life.
And this life continues into his 20s,
he's able to get married, have a child.
But at the age of 29 he's
able to leave the compound.
He's able to see the world
as it really is outside of
this world that his father
has created for him,
and he sees old age, he sees
sickness, he sees poverty,
and this creates a lot of
consternation in Siddhartha.
He wonders why this is so,
why is there this suffering
in the world?
And so he decides, once again, at age 29,
to seek the truth, to try
to understand the universe
as it is.
And remember, this is in
India where it was common
practice for religious
ascetics to go off into the
woods and to meditate about
the true nature of reality,
try to obtain moksha.
So he goes and follows that same practice.
And for six years, he is
going through the woods,
he's wandering, he's left all
of his possessions behind,
he has left his family behind.
He famously starts off
trying to go in the mold
of these Hindu ascetics,
letting go of everything,
including trying to deprive
the body of food and water,
and he almost kills himself.
But then eventually, at age
35, he makes his way to the
town of Gaya, now known as Bodh Gaya.
And over there he meditates
under a sacred fig tree,
later known as the Bodhi tree.
And he meditates there for seven days.
And on the seventh day, it strikes him,
he has a revelation, he
awakens, so to speak.
And according to Buddhist
tradition, from that moment
he becomes the Buddha,
or the awakened one.
And for the next 49 days he
makes no contact with anyone,
but he eventually makes
his way to Sarnath.
And at a deer park there he
re-encounters five of his
previous followers and
they had given up on him.
But now they see that
there's a change in Siddhartha,
now the Buddha.
And he begins to explain
to them what he has seen,
what he has discovered.
This is a quotation from the
Dhammacakkappavattana Sutta,
what is was called in the Pali language,
which was the language of Buddha's time.
And it can be translated as
Setting the Wheel of Dhamma,
which is another word for
Dharma, the (mumbles) word
Dharma, in motion.
And Dhamma in Hinduism
means this cosmological law.
What you should follow in your life.
Dhamma in Buddhism, or Dharma
in Buddhism can mean that,
but it can also mean the
teachings of Buddha and the
Dhammacakkappavattana Sutta.
The sayings of Buddha at
Sarnath are considered to be
his first teachings to his followers.
"There are these two
extremes that are not to be
"indulged in by one who has gone forth.
"Which two?
"That which is devoted
to sensual pleasure with
"reference to sensual
objects: base, vulgar, common,
"ignoble, unprofitable;
and that which is devoted
"to self affliction: painful,
ignoble, unprofitable.
"Avoiding both of these
extremes, the middle way
"leads to calm, to direct
knowledge, to self-awakening,
"to Unbinding."
So this is considered to
be Buddha's first reference
to the notion of the middle way.
And what's interesting here,
he's saying things that
are consistent with many
of the Hindu ascetics
of the time.
That you shouldn't devote
yourself to sensual pleasure,
with reference to sensual
objects, base, vulgar,
common, ignoble.
But he's also saying that
you shouldn't go the other
extreme either.
You shouldn't devote
yourself to self-affliction,
painful, ignoble, unprofitable.
That, too, is not going
to lead to the truth.
He says, avoid both of these
extremes, the middle way.
Now in the Dhammacakkappavattana
Sutta he goes on
to describe what are known
as four noble truths.
"Now this, monks, is the
noble truth of suffering,"
or dhukka, "Birth is
suffering, aging is suffering,
"death is suffering:
sorrow, lamentation, pain,
"distress, and despair are suffering.
"Association with the
unbeloved is suffering,
"separation from the loved is suffering.
"Not getting what is wanted is suffering."
So the first noble truth,
he's describing this notion
of dhukka, this notion of suffering.
And later on he goes to expand on it.
Saying it's not just
traditional notions of sorrow,
lamentation, pain, distress,
but it's also trying to
desire or pursue anything
that is temporary in nature
will eventually lead to
dhukka, or suffering.
"And this, monks, is the
noble truth of the origination
"of suffering, the craving
that makes for further
"becoming -- accompanied
by passion and delight,
"relishing now here, and
now there -- craving for
"sensual pleasure, craving for becoming,
"craving for non-becoming."
So that cause of the
suffering is this craving.
Craving for these impermanent things.
"And this, monks, is the
noble truth of the cessation
"of suffering: the remainderless
fading and cessation,
"renunciation, relinquishment, release,
"and letting go of that very craving."
So here he's saying, "Look,
you don't have to suffer,
"there's a way to escape from it."
And it's essentially to stop that craving.
That's the third noble truth.
"And this, monks, is the
noble truth of the way of
"practice leading to the
cessation of suffering."
So, how do you actually
practice life in way
that you can seize this suffering?
"Precisely this Noble Eightfold Path,"
which is another concept
which is quoted a lot in
Buddhism, this notion of
these eight things that
you need to do in order to
escape from this suffering,
from this dhukka, from this craving.
"Right view, right resolve,
right speech, right action,
"right livelihood, right
effort, right mindfulness,
"and right concentration."
This comes from the Dhammapada,
which you can interpret
as the path to dhamma.
And Buddha says, "All that
we are is the result of
"what we have thought: it
is founded on our thoughts,
"it is made up of our thoughts."
Which is a core idea in Buddhism.
That this notion of separateness,
this is just due to our thoughts,
it's all happening in our mind.
The psychical reality
that you think is somehow
more permanent than
the transient thoughts,
it's all happening in your thought,
it's all happening in your
mind and the separateness
is really an illusion.
And once again, very similar
idea to what we see in the
Upanishads.
Now one final idea, Buddha
taught throughout his life,
and eventually dies at Kushinagar,
which is one of those four
pilgrimage sites that we
saw on that map.
But really accelerated
the spread of Buddhism,
especially beyond India,
was the reign of the emperor
Ashoka during the Maurya Empire.
And we talk about Ashoka, we
have a whole video on him,
but he eventually converts to
Buddhism and he sponsors it,
he builds temples, and he
sponsors missionaries to
spread Buddhism from Europe
all the way to China.
And so Buddha was obviously
the central figure,
but Ashoka was the accelerant
that spread Buddhism
to the world.